[Music]
ready to migrate your virtual machines
to google cloud vmware engine let's take
a look at hcx
my name is raj jitnani with google cloud
and in this video we're going to walk
through how to deploy the htx connector
in your on-premises environment
and pair it up with htx manager on the
google cloud side in order to perform
migration steps such as bulk migration
vmotion or even network extensions
first thing we're going to do is walk
through the environment here where we
have our on-premises vcenter represented
with the orange
tab browser grouping as well as the
google cloud vmware engine vcenter
represented with the blue tab
while on the cloud side vcenter let's go
to the menu option and select hcx from
the dropdown
we'll head over to the administration
option under system
and this is where you can see what
version of hcx you currently have
deployed on the cloud side
whether you have a remote htx instance
that's already paired with this instance
as well as the ability to request a
download for the hdx connector
so we're gonna go ahead and do that
initiate the request for download and
click on the vmware hcx icon
in order to get the ovf deployed and
downloaded on your local machine
once this is complete we're going to
switch over to your on-premises vcenter
and from there select a cluster or
resource pool and deploy the ovf
now this wizard has been sped up for the
purposes of shortening the video but
during this wizard some key things to
keep in mind make sure that you have a
dns entry for your hdx connector vm so
it can resolve itself and the rest of
your infrastructure like your vcenter
name
and whatever network you select that it
has the capability to reach the
vmware management components within your
on-premises site
and the next thing we're going to do
here is fill in the rest of the fields
including the host name passwords
providing an ip address
making sure that you put in the domain
and dns information that we're going to
leverage
and of course the ntp server
now once the vm is deployed you'll be
able to reach the configuration page by
opening a browser and going to the url
or ip address of the vm but make sure to
add colon 9443 at the end of it as you
can see on the screen and you can now
log in with the admin and the
credentials that was specified during
the ovf deployment
once logged in the first thing we're
going to do is activate hcx in order for
it to reach vmware's activation server
the connector does need to be able to
reach port 443 on
connect.hcx.vmware.com and in order to
get the license key you can go to the
gcp portal and under the htx manager
section download the hdx activation key
so let's go ahead and do that and
activate
next thing we're going to do is select
which physical location our on-premises
data center is located in
and continue
and for the system name it does add a
dash enterprise to the end of that just
to identify the system name you can
leave that as is or i generally prefer
removing that to match it up to the
fully qualified domain name
let's go ahead and restart and activate
the configuration for hcx
next we're going to put in how we talk
to vcenter itself what username and
permissions you want to use what service
account for example let's go ahead and
hit continue now in the identity source
you can reuse the same url like your
vcenter address or if you have a
separate psc
make sure to put that in here
once this is complete go ahead and
restart the services this will take a
few minutes for it to complete so be a
little patient with it and then you'll
be greeted with a new screen that shows
the configuration and state of the
services for hcx
now you should see plugins being
deployed in your vcenter you may have to
refresh your browser to see it
but if you go to menu you'll see hcx
listed there and the dashboard will load
the next thing we're going to do is do a
side pairing so this will connect your
on-prem hdx connector to the cloud hcx
manager
first thing we're going to do is copy
the hdx url on the cloud side by going
to the hdx manager under administration
you'll see system name
and we can leverage that for the address
go ahead and type in https and then add
in the url
also make sure that your on-premises
environment can resolve the cloud side
management components by dns name before
doing this
go ahead and type in the cloud owner
username in our example here to pair the
two sites if you've already tied your
active directory to
google cloud vmware engine you can
leverage permissions there as well for
service accounts
and there we have it we have our on-prem
connector connected with our google
cloud
htx manager thanks for watching and for
additional steps on how to configure the
next components of hcx continue watching
the video series and you'll be able to
get insight into how to configure a
service mesh and perform a vm migration
to learn more about google cloud vmware
engine visit our site at
cloud.google.com
vmware dash engine
[Music]
you